from city to city small cafes to
individual homes there are a few things
that are truly Universal one of them
however is coffee over two billion cups
are drunk every day but not all coffee
is created equal so we've traveled to
five countries and met five people to
show us how truly unique this one common
drink can be
[Music]
unsurprisingly for many coffee marks the
start of the day yes - acostumbrado will
revel in la mañana cuando me despierto
pay no se puede tomar en cualquier
momento el dia medium Oh juicy a vivo
and Cidade a Mexico s cafeteria is some
people diferente de cafe específico de
mexico ibaka fair Cohen appeal on CEO
que es una supernatural yah Cannella en
algunas receptive a poner tambien
cascara dinara nomicon inferno pena
tarragon net Uno's and official nebula
animal SOC silicon new home which is
rather a nut McConkey a does Mottola
after a bullet in mañana por la casa la
técnica that eliminate not any leads on
me and then nothing is inevitable me
[Music]
O'Donnell lembaga wanna give not eaten
Anthony cup although the preparations
may differ one thing is clear coffee and
culture are intertwined capsules the
very body and symbols being on civilian
fingermark till two years or another
during the song Miska today
come on saying women so many harder than
you some may say I read second a hundred
and some people also 18 to further or
American handle for the fans doing a
sheer scope fellas all the aldermen
capitalist and or plate and some torque
as a kendama cultivar of the New York
subway ridiculous truck or car first and
then and fire an ad 30 capital or Embree
not arrows can be harmed in a restaurant
[Music]
everywhere cafe Mexico's es muy
importante porque para la cienaga
when the revolution mexicana s take
effect in low prepare evangelist
Adelitas kids on las mujeres
soldados Ypres para esta casa para darle
mass in F here a los hombres as the day
progresses the evening marks the start
of a different kind of coffee culture
cafe life pistola
- aha yet neither my weekly fan cafe for
Celine 90 more my mad at me yep can't a
man got a while about Newton I like a
few children to new Gilliam fine wine
oil and a vintage hahahhahahhaha these
are equally efficient Sorachi what's our
take on Van Gogh is a might not a word
or fact a team and one team that was
Alex you on the way over Toby will die
quickly quickly Jeannie come on Vanunu
means young no one got away
Nickelodeon and IndieGoGo say that in
[Music]
Korea sounded earth
arkad I shall be a lady from be City
polo video again I'll declare caffeine
all attributable Kavya from the cargo
digas entity neo mr. mr. mr. La Silla as
al-anam behave a cool adult or did bill
Baruch danke I wish my cigarette cook
shaken Michaela Sasha Salamanca nuclear
only tribunal exactly in conversation
now that is vicarage secure entire
category Missa est de segura da da
officio no katachi did you know the
makino Bush in the American Jews V dole
do sumo I carry it probably some hour to
opinion there is of course the one main
draw of coffee that we all know to be
universal the kick a banjo kazooie to be
carried to consume some our town Sola
action bars and readin a green dude on
the couch potato telecined officinalis
in the FISMA Bahamas
sauce Ibaka
Marika cafe hello doc particular tango
[Music]
in addition to the aforementioned coffee
of course unites us all creo que esta
fair with assertive la gente Annette
llamas relacionado Yaakov a New Zealand
a chakras all marketers who Libya that
an asana Oh like average effective as a
marketed mixture media coverage in here
in Italian well you know while in
detector say tinnitus can tell and I
know he knows it can't you knock I do
not have his native lucky normally
doesn't data before free now in Cabana
Hey
[Music]